ich lese vor was die menschheit zu darf
ich wissen will ist zwar hätten dadurch
zuliebe herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen video leute ich habe in meiner
seite jana und max und wir beschäftigen
uns heute mit der dummheit von menschen
wie das ganze funktioniert ist sehr
einfach unser folge haben die beiden
treten gegen ihn an max gegen seine
freundin jana die haben die ordner mit
zettel drauf und ich werde den beiden
gleich anfänge von google-suchanfragen
vorlesen und dann müssen die raten
welche ultra dummen vorschlägen google
zu diesen suchanfragen gemacht hat und
wenn er mich jetzt fragt was hat das mit
dummen menschen zu tun
google macht das weil leute sowas
wirklich suchen
er werde gleich sehen wir uns mal okay
was jetzt soll ich jetzt teil von der
sofort folge vor und dann müsst ihr den
ersten fünf vorschlägen die google
gemacht hat mit drei antworten die er
aufschreiben dürft die meisten richtigen
treffer raus wollen dürfte jede
suchabfrage drei vervollständigung
aufschreiben ok und das schauen wir ob
es sei in den top fünf vorschlägen von
gebieten sind erst heute das passiert
werden max zwei minuten lang keine
beschäftigten kämpft vier helfer denn
ich bin nur 1000 leute suchen zudem
anfang ist das illegale geschäft reise
ab und müsste damit möglichst viele aus
den ersten fünf vorschlägen treffen
die dümmsten okay dann bitte auch
vorschläge vor
ist es illegal bekifft auto zu fahren
nein mit autofahren ist es nicht dann
aber es gibt tatsächlich den vorschlag
ist es illegal haie zu sein
ok eine feine weine anders ist es
illegal drogen zu nehmen
das ist nah genug das war die
realistischen abgedrehten sagen mein
freund auf die wahrscheinlich wissen
[Musik]
schneller
dann hab ich noch da ist egal ob der
straße zu pinkeln
oh mein gott mein dass ich dabei ich
habe dann das zimmer gedanke ist es
illegal sechs kommentiert haben
aber wie schreibt ja dahinter nein das
ist egal einen polizisten zu schlagen
es sei nicht fair das ist es illegal
nacht zu furzen die richtigen super
fragen warten ist es illegal hand
zusammen zu kaufen ist es illegal zu
streamen dann ist das billiger westen zu
töten ist illegal zu sein und ist es
illegale filme zu zwingen ist er ja wenn
sie bei netflix und und irgendwie der
regel nicht suchanfrage ist rihanna ist
so eine dumme antwort okay dann fangen
die alle tasten schwerer ist okay machst
du ich habe mir ist designerin blau im
gesicht
shanti hatte
wir sollten hier marke für dessous und
[Musik]
kraft sei er war vollkommen daneben
weil was die menschen interessiert zu
werden er ist natürlich rihannas
schwanger dann natürlich wie bei jeder
person die irgendwie bekannt wird rea
ist tot dann rihanna ist wie groß
rihanna ist ein mann und nummer fünf ist
natürlich das ist das ganz kurz nur wenn
man jetzt folgenden fall
jana hat gerade eben nur reich single
und geil vorgelesen und natürlich steht
mit schrägstrich dies nicht gerade eben
hinzugefügt wurden auf einmal alle
richtigen antworten da sagt ehrlich hast
du übrigens auch leute mich hat das war
aufgefallen dass es auch unter videos
koreaner dabei ist oft gemeine
kommentare darunter stehen zu mir und
ich würde gerne bitten seid einfach
freundlich zu jana ok alles klar der
nächste superstar ist darf ich kann
sicher sagen dass sich in der top 5
platz sieben ist darf ich westen okay
was darf ich ist eigentlich das gleiche
wie ist es illegal besteht dadurch kann
es zu kaufen darf ich drogen nehmen und
auf jeden fall mein erstes darf ich gras
raucht und dann darf ich autofahren
da habe ich früher schwester schlagen
ich lese vor was die menschheit zu darf
ich wissen will ist um erhalten dadurch
zu diesem richtigen kunstfreund hätte
[Musik]
grund sondern unter kaltes 20 darf ich
bitten das dritte ist da schon bald
[ __ ]
das dritte ist schauen wir wo die erste
war eigentlich badisch konnte
da hab ich dann diese gruppe leitet das
ist auch so dann kommen davon nummer
vier
da war ich vorstellen sollten nummer
fünf ist da was zu dir mehr kleinere
oder nicht ist kann man einen punkt okay
ich sage ja dürfte siebensachen
abstatten und fertig ok alles klar kann
man einfach ohne essen und kann sondern
eine kapuze fixiert
sicher kann man 80 feste töten kann man
an die kirche essen und kann man eine
kleine feine steine platz für karmann
rheine ist kann man eine lederhose
waschen das 2 ist kann von deinen platz
3 bekommt kommen wir also diese wirklich
spannend technischen fragen platz drei
ist hier kann bereits zu begründen
gebt das hier ist kann man eine pdf
datei vom platz fünf ist natürlich die
frage die wir uns jeden tag stellen kann
man eine couch zurückgeben muss los oder
[Musik]
doch lieber das java kindisches roman
ich möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen ist wieder leute ich bringe
die beiden jetzt wieder die
mittagsbetreuung
wir sind in dem slogan für linke
reinmacht gut und zeigt hier eine folge
was geht ab